très important pour moi de présenter mon
pays et surtout
des faire savoir et comment les
Burkinabè se préparent à côté du sport
c'est toi un athlétisme c'est vraiment
important pour moi et c'est c'est à moi
de me donner à fond et pour que les gens
puissent savoir comment nous nous
préparons un pays et pour faire des
vélos
[Musique]
d'abord c'était le football mais j'ai
pas eu au club mais dans les quartiers
comme ça et du coup quand j'ai eu mon CP
et à l'âge de 16 ans
[Applaudissements]
à l'école d'abord et après quelques mois
on m'a mis dans un club et j'ai commencé
maintenant à m'entraîner tous les jours
tous les jours et voilà et d'ici une
année comme ça j'ai fait m'exprimer
cette mètre et les 14 mètres autour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec avec moi et à d'autres aussi qui ne
sont pas avec moi bien sûr qui
n'acceptent pas et que je mets beaucoup
de temps et sur l'athlétisme il y a
beaucoup il faut faire et de continuer à
l'école et d'autres aussi et m'encourage
de continuer comme ça en atteler et
puisque c'est un moyen aussi de réussir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]